let's get the thoughts of labour now
we're joined once again in the studio by
the shadow working pension secretary
jonathan ashworth good to see you this
morning um
given that which we've we've just been
hearing in and around mario paul kiev
lev we are hearing any number of stories
of atrocities taking place on the ground
in ukraine do you understand why the
government feels unable to go quite as
far as the ukrainian president and
describe
these as war crimes as genocide and
indeed identify vladimir putin as
responsible for them well they are
heinous atrocities absolutely
appalling in my view there are crimes
now i'm not an international lawyer so
there may well be
particular definitions but what we are
seeing coming out of ukraine are is
absolutely the most appalling scenes
i do hold putin responsible
he needs to be held to account and the
international community need to find a
way to do that but we need to continue
to do all we can to support ukraine we
need to support the refugees
and i've got nothing but absolute
tribute to everybody who has donated to
the different charity appeals including
in my own leicester constituency where
i've been supporting it we need to do
all we can and of course we need to
ensure that the maximum pressure is put
on russia through the sanctions regime i
mean you you say that vladimir putin
indeed as did such a java this morning
that he that he must be held to account
i suppose the question is how is that
possible given you're not going to be
able to extradite them to the icc well
there will have to come a point where
the international community needs to
come together and decide how to hold him
to account but in the immediate term
we've got to support the refugees coming
out of ukraine with the proper
humanitarian assistance i know the
government has is putting in place
schemes but i've been reading that the
the charity groups and local authorities
that the government are understandably
asking for help have been left in the
lurch don't know
what what provisions are going to get
what support they're going to get so we
need clarity from government as to how
they're going to help the refugees in
the short term but of course we need to
as an international community work
together internationally to put in place
a plan in order to hold russia to
account but what then did you make of of
the prime minister's remarks to the
conservative spring conference i've
heard from the health secretary this
morning we heard from the chancellor
yesterday claiming that he was not
drawing a direct comparison between the
two he certainly mentioned them in short
in short succession well he was drawing
a direct comparison but you know what
you know why he was doing it he know
he's a clever operator he's a very good
manipulator he throws these things out
there to suck the oxygen out of the
other big issues that are around and
he's trying to distract people from the
cost of living crisis where nine million
families are going to be 500 pounds
worth of where he's imposing this
punishing tax rise
on people where pensioners are going to
lose 388 pounds and the value of the
basic state pension he's just doing it
so we all sort of have a row on that
rather than focus on the issues that are
impacting the british people day in day
out which is the fact that many of them
are facing starving or freezing in the
words of martin lewis the money-saving
expert i i want to talk about that in a
bit more depth in just a second but
let's talk about something completely on
your briefing the situation as regards
piano ferries 800 individuals fired with
apparently no warning
what is it that the labourer are trying
to seek in the commons today is this
just a rerun of the efforts made by
barry gardner beforehand to get you know
fire and rehard as a practice band we
need action from the government i mean
the way piano have acted uh piano
ferries have acted towards their uh uh
seafaring workforce areas beyond content
it's absolutely disgusting
is it legal though uh by your
understanding is it illegal because
again what neither of us are lawyers
there are there are plenty of lawyers
who suggest that it perhaps wasn't well
but that's why we need clarity from the
government as i understand it the
government knew this was going to happen
and didn't tell anyone i mean what are
they playing at by the way i've got
nothing but tribute for the rmt union
and carl turner he's one of the local
mps and actually louis hague my
colleague the shadow transport secretary
has been they have all been superb in
fighting for these workers but these
practices should be outlawed and the
government the business secretary should
be looking into the legalities of it he
should be if they believe it is illegal
looking at criminal proceedings against
the uh
the bosses of this firm and the and if
there's no good tory mps ringing their
hand saying he's all terrible many of
them voted against the legislation which
a labour mp brought forward to ban these
fire and rehire practices and they
should vote with us today in the house
of commons to ban these fire and rehire
type practices but what what can the
government do bar wholesale changes to
legislation about you know a company
like p o ferries hiring via foreign
agencies individuals on less than the
minimum wage
they need to stump it out they need to
stamp it out they don't need to parade
around the studios after this morning oh
we'll say it's terrible i was shocked by
the shocked when i saw it on my on the
screens as well you know they're the
government they can do something about
it and tory mps can do something about
it so they should vote with us today to
send a message to the business secretary
and others in the cabinet that they need
to fix this
just a quick word then from what you
would like to see from from the
chancellor come wednesday his hands are
are not exactly tied there's quite a bit
of extra cash flowing floating around in
the treasure at the moment thanks to the
rise in the cost of living and the extra
tax take that they're taking so where
should he be spending well look you know
we've had 12 years of economic
mismanagement which has left us so
exposed to surging inflation and that
now means we've got rising energy bills
so unaffordable we've got tax rises so
punishing universal credit cuts so
severe basic state pension cuts so
devastating that people as martin luther
says are facing a choice between
starving or freezing he should increase
the uh he shouldn't be cutting benefits
like the pension and universal credit he
shouldn't be going ahead with this big
national insurance rise a 10
increase he could put a windfall tax on
the oil and gas producers to fund 600
pounds for off the of the heating bills
for many households so there is action
the chancellor should take and he should
take it in his money budget on wednesday
well we'll find out if he's been
listening to you then uh jonathan
ashworth thanks for joining us thanks a
lot